if anyone can save arendelle its you hey
also we get that you're faced with a
huge challenge in frozen - and we give
you props for your determination to run
across the ocean but your continual
attempts to get over those waves is
bordering on obsession and we want to
know more about this fascinating side to
you
you'll learn to open up your heart to
Anna by the end of the first movie but
there's plenty more room for you to grow
we want to see you open up about your
dark side okay that's definitely not
what I thought you were gonna say
there's no denying that Elsa is a
complex character we hardly scratched
the surface of all the turmoil within
her in the first movie so frozen - needs
to talk about Elsa's dark side keep
watching to the end to discover how Elsa
could learn to rein in the magic that
surrounds her Elsa's issues in frozen
elsa suffers from self-doubt in the
first movie it's no wonder given that
she was traumatized at a young age her
upbringing stunted her emotional growth
since she was told to conceal don't feel
all cephalic upper Dhin and her
insecurities made her want to isolate
herself she even celebrated her
isolation in let it go Elsa's distance
from Anna when Elsa's ice powers were
revealed at her coronation party she ran
away she abandoned her sister and her
Kingdom she didn't mean it she didn't
mean any of this this was Elsa's
opportunity to open up and tell Anna
about her powers before they were
exposed so why didn't she Rosen - needs
to explore this could it be that Elsa
doesn't feel she deserves love or
support Elsa's self-destructive behavior
judging from the frozen two trailers it
looks like we're going to finally get
some insight into Elsa self-destructive
behavior the pink flame fire is even
more intriguing when we see Elsa tell
Anna follow me
an honor response and don't run into
fire it's such a telling moment
revealing so much about Elsa's dark side
Elsa the villain it's well known that
Elsa was originally going to be a
villain so that could explain why we
don't get a satisfying in-depth
character exploration in the first movie
it focused more on Ana's development
which is great but frozen 2 looks set to
balance that by zooming in on Elsa and
also showing us how other characters
view her in the trailer Anna asks
Christoph has Elsa seemed weird to you
and he replies she seems like awesome
that speaks volumes doesn't it Elsa an
honest reconnection sure by the end of
frozen Elsa had reconnected with Anna
but the movie didn't address some of the
deep-rooted issues that were instilled
in Elsa from a young age frozen to looks
set to write that by sending Elsa on a
quest that will help her overcome her
issues find who is pulling we all want
Elsa to finally accept love into our
life but how could that happen
Elsa's love life any fan will say they
want to see Elsa and a happy romantic
relationship but we don't think Disney
is going to give that to us in frozen to
what we hope to get however is a deeper
sisterly relationship the trailers have
given us lots of clues that this will
happen and that Elsa will allow herself
to rely on others she asked Sanne
what would I do without you honest
belief in Elsa it looks like Ana's going
to play a huge part in helping Elsa
finally believe in herself and accept
help from others in the trailer Allah
tells Elsa that she's going with her on
her quest of course Elsa says no but
then Anna points out that she climbed
the North Mountain survived a frozen
heart and saved also from Hans so she's
definitely coming ona aunts promise me
we do this together okay
and also replies I promise we also see
Anna explicitly say to her sister I
believe
more than anyone or anything else's
journey into the unknown Allison needs
on a support and she has a huge mission
in frozen to after all Abby tells her
across the enchanted land and people
unknown this journey into the unknown is
so important they've made a song with
that title the lyrics explain Elsa's
struggle she sings about a voice she can
hear who no she's not where she's meant
to be she finds every day is a little
harder and she longs to go into the
unknown that sure does sound like a
metaphor for living life right on the
edge Elsa's dangerous magic Elsa clearly
does venture into the unknown thanks to
her magical powers will they be a
hindrance or a home as poppy says we
have always feared houses powers were
too much for this world and now we must
hold
but it seems like Elsa will struggle to
stay in a balanced place with her powers
Bobby warns onna magic disappearing
without you see baby knows herself the
second movie we'll have to explore this
dark side of Elsa's powers Elsa's
excitement it certainly looks like Elsa
is ready to embrace the excitement of
being magical and that he's calling us
she literally lets her hair down as she
jumps down a series of icy blocks that
she conjures but can't she control it
there's a scene in the trailer that
suggests Elsa finds a way to rein in her
powers it's when we see her rein in a
spirit horse and ride it what do you
hope to learn about Elsa and frozen - be
sure to let us know in the comments make
sure to subscribe to the themes for more
frozen 2 videos like this one thanks for
watching we'll see you soon